字幕: Yuko Shirakawa
校正: Himaro Toyoshima
なぜ皆さんはプレゼンテーションをするんでしょうか
そしてなぜ皆さんは今日プレゼンテーションを聞きに
来たんですか
なんででしょう
簡単です
このTED TEDxのテーマ
Ideas worth spreading
そうですよね アイディアをみんなで広めましょう
でも どうやってこのアイディアを本当に
広めるんでしょうか
実際にこのプレゼンテーションを聞いて
素晴らしいアイディアを 皆さん得るかもしれません
これを実際に活用する
そういったプロセスまで進んだことがありますか
私もたくさんTEDxトーク TEDトークを観ました
でも実現したもの
実践したものはごく限られているんです
なんか映画のように素晴らしいものとして見て
それで終わっていることって
ありませんか
そこで今日は このプレゼンテーションを
その先に進める
いかに自分のものにするか っていう話を
私が大学で プレゼンテーションに関する
研究をしながら得た
結果をふまえて
考察したいと思います
アイディアを広げるのは 人々です
プレゼンターだけではなく
オーディエンスがこのアイデアを広め
ここに来なかった人たちが
この情報を得て理解 納得を得る
そして共感につなげる
こういった行為につながって
初めてプレゼンテーションは
パワーを持つんです
つまり いかに人を動かすか ということが重要なんです
わたしはつい数年前
大病を患い 生死を彷徨いました
ICU(集中治療室)でしばらく意識がなく
やっとこの大病から生還をし
生還したけど残念ながら
臆病という病気にかかったんです
何かチャレンジすることに 非常に
引っ込み思案になってしまいました
ところがある友人から
スキー場の頂上で
プレゼンテーションをしてくれ
という依頼を頂いたんです
行ってみて驚きました
彼らは山頂でアイロンがけを始めたんです
これは異様な光景でした
私はまず理解ができませんでした
ところが彼らをよく見てみると
非常に楽しんでいるんですね
中にはスーツの方もいます
ネクタイにアイロン掛けたりもしています
この周りにはもう20人ぐらいの仲間がいて
心からこの行為を
楽しんでいるんですね
私は最初こうしてビデオを撮りながら
傍観者を気取っていました
ところが私の友人が
やってみたらどうか
というふうに言ってくれたのでやってみました
何とも言えない 爽快感 達成感 そして
なんだか分からない征服感
こういったものを得たんです
ぜひ皆さん 山の山頂で
アイロンがけをしてみてください
これつまり私の心が動かされたってことなんですね
どんなプレゼンテーションよりも
私の心に響いたんです
そして
自分でこれをやってみようと思い
アイロンを買いに行きました
これまで私アイロンかけたことなかったんです
さすがに高いアイロンはいきなり買えませんでした
とりあえずこの旅行用の小さいもの
そしてどうやら外でアイロンをかける
というものがあるらしい
その書籍も買い求め
アイロン台も購入し
まず最初 スキーを滑りながら
アイロンをかけてみました （笑）
私は元々スキーのレーサーです
これは会津若松で
この私の友人たちが
福島の復興のために
もう福島は安全だよと
観光客を誘致しようという
行為の一環でおこなっている
"Smile for Fukushima"という活動です
ここで少しスピードをあげたりして
チャレンジするっていうことで私は臆病から
初めて脱することができました
ここでかけているのは会津織そして
赤べこです (笑)
地元のものをかけると
こういったものにはルールはありません
沖縄ではアロハシャツ
海の中ではもうなにも考えません
まずここにシワがあるかどうかが分からない (笑)
シワが伸びているかどうかが分からない （笑）
これはもうまさに無の境地です（笑）
まるで禅の心得ですよね
そうすることで私 いろいろなものを得ました
このときにはちょっとアイロンが大きくなってます
海底洞窟の中でかけてみると
自分の心の中が透けて見えるような
感覚を得ました
これは青の洞窟といい宮古島の海底洞窟です
非常に美しい景色の中で
美しいものに心打たれながら
自分の心をもう一回覗いてみよう
という新しい行為を
私 得ることができました
おそらくこんな水中で
アイロン掛けているヤツは
世の中にいないだろうと思い
私は一時期 自尊心を満たしていたんですが
驚愕の事実がわかりました
いろいろ調べてみたところ
ギネス記録に 173人 10分間
水中アイロンというのが
2011年にもうすでに記録としてあるんですね（笑）
無知っていうのは怖いです（笑）
海の中でアイロンをかけると
あがった時にこれ絞りますよね
またシワができます
これが無限ループです（笑）
エクストリームアイロンがけ
という項目がヒットしました
これは1997年 イギリス発祥の
国際スポーツです
あらゆる過酷な状況で
心の冷静さを試すのだそうです
やってみました
いろいろ調べてみたら
アイロンをかける人 アイロニストには
こういった精神があるそうです
羞恥心をまず克服すること
ユーモア感覚
大自然の厳しさに立ち向かう強靱な肉体
ばかばかしさの理解
そして当然これは家事です
家事にはセンスが必要です
北海道へ行ったり
山にのぼったり
まずこのザックに
アイロン台を入れるところから勝負です
こんなの本当に持って行っていいんだろうか
この脚を分解し自作をしました
そしたらバッグに入らないんですね
まるで昔の
フレームバッグのようでした
これが結構岩にあたって危険でした
山を登るときにすれ違う人に
「あれそれなんですか？」
「どう見てもアイロン台でしょう」
「あれ何してるんですか」
「いや どう見てもアイロンでしょう」という
こういう当たり前の行為が
当たり前じゃなくなるという
非日常の共有という
新しい経験を得ることができました
筑波山の山頂でアイロンを掛けた時には
周りにギャラリーがたくさん集まり
この喜びを
笑顔として伝染させていることに気づいたんです
この笑顔は増幅します
どんどんみんなが
特に子どもたちが
何も考えずに
この喜びに勤しむということを
この極限状態で得る
といったことに気付いたんです
これつまり心のシワを伸ばしているんですね
凍った湖の上で掛けたときは
氷に亀裂が入っていることに
気づきませんでした
（笑）
ここから私の冒険が始まります
スキーをしながらアイロンを掛ける
これかなりスピードが出てるんですが
お気づきになったでしょうか
アイロン台がかなり大きくなってきてます
アイロンもかなり大きいです
これは吾妻小富士という福島にある火山の火口です
このように一人で掛けることで自分の心を試す
そういった行為もあるんですが
100年前に実は
この桜島は土砂に埋もれて
この中に昔 部落が存在したんですね
試しに行ってみたいと思いました
ここでよく見ると
私アイロンをかけてます
何もない場だからこそ
人は素に帰れるんですね
こうなるともう心が解放されます（笑）
みんなでアイロン掛けに行こうよ と誘ったんですが
なかなかみんなは最初のってくれませんでした
そこでいかに自分が楽しいか
ということを体で示しました
これは遠隔アイロニングです
（笑）
心のシワ[だけ]ではなく 体のシワをのばします
ここで誰よりも飛距離を伸ばすと
真摯に向かえば人は真似をするのです（笑）
真摯な態度に人って心を打たれますね
こういった大きな発見を得ました
真摯な姿に人が動くんです
これってまさに モチベーションですね
報酬や外的要素のモチベーションではなくて
内的な要素から浮かび上がるモチベーション
動機付けなんです
心から楽しみたい
自分でしかも工夫したい
そして今よりもちょっと成長したい
こういった思いがあれば
人は心を動かすと言われています
まさにこの行為はそれを
身をもって体験する素晴らしい経験になりました
これはスキーとスノーボードで
タンデムでアイロンを掛けている
おそらく世界初の試みになったでしょう
ここでまさにプレゼンテーションと同じ
共感が生まれたんです
ここまでくるとみんな
じゃあ 俺はこういう風にする
じゃあ 俺はこういう風にしよう
という新しい創造性が浮かび上がります
これはドローンというヘリコプターで
空撮をしている様子です
なかなか空撮でアイロンを撮影するとは
彼らも思わなかったでしょう
これは滝の裏側です
こういったところに挑戦するときに
私もひとつ
また気付いたことがありました
これは自分の心の壁を越えている
ていうことなんです
みなさん自分でいろんな限界を作ってませんか
それを超えるきっかけ どうしてますか
こういったエクストリームな行為
そして自分の心に正直に向き合う
そうすると心の壁は越えられるんです
我々の仲間はいろいろなところでも 既に
アイロン行為に勤しみ
中には裸で
ガッツポーズをしている外国人もいます
すべてのシワには
そのストーリーがあるんです
ここでひとつ実験をしてみました
どうやったらみんなはこのアイロンを
楽しんでもらえるか
初心者の場合 なかなか
アイロンを楽しんでくれません
私はとりあえずこういったところで
これ洞窟です
こういうバカな行為をしながらですね
自分のいかにこう楽しめるかという心を試します
もうなかなかここまでやってですね
このとき私の友人が1人いたんですが
彼に「アイロンとはね 心のシワを伸ばすんだよ」
「こういう風にするんだよ」って
いろいろ教えすぎたんです
そしたら彼一応笑顔なんですけど
ちょっと引きつってます
なかなか なんでもかんでも教えて
説明してこういう風にしろっていうと
その通り楽しめないんですね
そこで実験２です
このときは何も教えず
ただ私が楽しみました
そしていかにこれが楽しいかを
簡単に伝え
これをすぐ真似できるような形にしたんです
これはロケットを実際に打ち上げている所ですね
そうしたところ
私の友人はノリノリでした（笑）
これがいかに楽しいかを
彼はもう自分で理解しているんですね
なによりかけながら
自分で楽しいということに気づいてくれるんです
ここ 彼が自分の心の壁を崩し越えた瞬間です
まさか大の大人が
ロケットの上に乗るとは思わなかったでしょう
（笑）
でもこういった行為は
非常にバカバカしいんですが
伝染をするんですね
むしろ私よりもこの若い彼の方がノリノリでした (笑)
こういったものには答えはありません
これはシカゴの
世界最大のティラノサウルスの恐竜の前です
高校生の修学旅行生がたくさん集まってきて
外国人はすぐ声かけてくれます
「え？ 何やってんの？」
「アイロンに決まってるんだろ」
（笑）
これはグランドキャニオンです
こういった行為は自分が楽しむ以外にも
人を楽しませることができるんです
こうして人生のシワを伸ばしながら
人と感動を共有することができます
これは先々週行ったモンサンミッシェルです
この干潟の上でアイロンを掛けるのが私の夢でした
何にもない干潟
そしてその裏側には モンサンミッシェル
素晴らしい修道院があります
こういったところで
なんで俺こんなことやってるんだろう
と思いながら自分の心が見えていき
解放されているという気分になってくるんです
外国の観光客はどんどん声をかけてくれます
「なにやっての？」
そこで私は答えます
「エクストリーム！」
自分の心の壁を越えるんです
これはモンサンミシェルの壁の上です
実際かなり危険です
エクストリームアイロニング
ひとつ原則があります
アイロンがなくても
エクストリームでなければいけないんです
これは実際僕もかなりビビりました
これはパリのエッフェル塔の前ですね
これを掛けながらですね
実は警備員がやってきました
ピーポーピーポーって音が遠くで
実は聞こえるんですけれど
ときにはこっそりやらなきゃいけない時もあります
急いで逃げている様子です
（笑）
観光客がたくさん声をかけてくれます
中にはチップを投げようする人もいます
いやこれはパフォーマンスではありません
エッフェル塔の上に登ったときは
非常に不思議な体験をしました
みんながカメラに向かって
笑顔を作ってくれるんですね
ここではもういろんな国籍の方がいらっしゃいました
このように非日常を共有することで
新しい価値が生まれる
これを体感することができたんです
どんどん声をかけてくれて
こういった行為こそみんなで
シェアするべきだというふうに
私は考えました
この非日常の共有
例えば これはパラオの海底洞窟 ブルーホールです
美しい景色の中でアイロンを掛けると
本当に心が無になるんですね
すべて自分が解放されます
中にはプロのカメラマンが私の写真を撮ってました
魚ではなくて
このアイロン
普通に家庭にあればなんでもないですよね
でもダイビングボートの上にあると
不思議なギアになります
みんな非常に興味津々です
ただのアイロンなんですけどね
このようにですね
どんどん心のシワを伸ばせば
人々がどんどん笑顔になってくる
それが生まれてくるっていうことを学びました
これこそがみんなで共有すべき
素晴らしいアイディアだと思います
そしてここに 新しいシワが生まれるんです
今まで眉間に寄っていた
「なんだこれ？」っていうシワが
目尻の笑顔のシワに変わっていくんです
人が動くにはまず真摯に相手を想うこと
そして自分がまず動くこの勇気を持つことが
重要ということを
私はこのエクストリーム・アイロニングから学びました
そして自分の壁をまず越える勇気を持ち
相手が壁を越えられるような
そんな希望を持たせる
こういった行為が
このエクストリーム・アイロニングの中にはある
という風に私は確信をし
これはベルリンの壁でアイロン掛けをしてみました
こういった行為に
エクストリーム・アイロニング・ジャパンという
日本で代表的な組織の代表の松澤等さん
第一人者といわれています
彼はどう思ってるか メールを投げました
そしたら素晴らしいお返事をいただいております
ほとばしるスチームのような
熱いメールありがとうございます
そしてこのエクストリーム・アイロニング・ジャパンに
私もメンバーとして加わることができました
日本で18人目だそうです
今日の朝も彼 メールをくれました
彼もこういった固定観念を
持ってるわけではないんです
自己責任でそれぞれが楽しむ
これがベストだという風に
彼が言っており まさに私がここが
共感するポイントだったと思います
彼のメールの最後には必ず
Keep the iron hot! と書いてあります（笑）
人を動かすんではないんです
人が動くんです
真摯さこそがこの壁を越える勇気なんです
私は今日 この鹿児島の皆さん
TEDxKagoshimaの皆さん
TEDxKagoshimaUniversityの皆さんに
こういった想いを
この鹿児島の桜島の灰の上で
気付かせてくれたことを
心から感謝したいと思い
これを今日のプレゼンテーションに
まさにプレゼントとして
皆さんにお届けしたい
というふうに思い
今日この場に立ちました
ありがとうございました